well I hope that during the five years
when I was a social studies teacher up
in the Bronx that I was at least a
little bit impactful on my students and
I think with me and my students it
helped that i was pretty close to them
in age and i think it helped that i was
just really excited to be teaching them
and i think i hope hopefully infected
some of them with with my enthusiasm for
for the subject matter i was teaching
and you know when i look back there were
some there were some really tough kids
who you know a couple of whom would
would write me birthday cards on my
birthday and and do things that were
really sweet which they probably never
would have admitted to amongst their
classmates but i did get to experience
that that bond between teacher and
student for five years and it was i
think really what prompted me to start
donorschoose.org but in terms of what it
is about teachers that has so many
people citing them as as their role
models i don't know i guess it's just
that they're they're sort of like a
junior parent always the one that the
teachers who who you really like
you